Smart. Less. Media. Hey guys, so Smart Less Media has a new show coming out. It's called Staying Alive. It's awesome. It's hosted by Adam Pally and John Grabus. And, sorry, Gay Bris. Gay Bris. I changed the R and the A. I don't know. No, no, no.
Smart Less Media。嘿大家，Smart Less Media 有个新节目要上线了。节目叫《Staying Alive》（保持活力）。非常棒。由 Adam Pally 和 John Gabrus 主持。抱歉，是 Gay Bris。Gay Bris。我把 R 和 A 的位置弄反了。我不知道。不，不，不。
Please, I do it. It's fine. Gay Bris. Also, there is something garbous and gar know if it's something you do all the time. Please, I do it. It's fine. Also, there is something garbous and garbled. There's something garbage and looking at John. It's like there's something that you wanna just say. There's a lot of work going on there. Mons pubis.
拜托，我来吧。没关系。Gay Bris。还有，有些东西是 garbous 和 gar，不知道这是否是你经常做的事。拜托，我来吧。没关系。还有，有些东西是 garbous 和 garbled。有些东西是垃圾，看着 John。就像有些话你想说出来。那里有很多工作要做。阴阜。
By the way, we can talk about that in a whole episode. So, it premieres Thursday, April 24th, which is just around the corner. And new episodes released every Thursday. You guys, I'm so happy you guys are doing this. It's very exciting. Please tell, because I fucking do a horrible job, please tell us what it's about.
顺便说一下，我们可以在整集节目中讨论这个问题。它将于 4 月 24 日星期四首播，就在眼前了。每周四发布新剧集。伙计们，我很高兴你们在做这个。非常令人兴奋。请告诉我们，因为我做得太烂了，请告诉我们它是关于什么的。
Look, this is so exciting. You are one of our pod fathers. I guess in our contract, you requested we call you that. So we're so excited to be part of this. I'm acting like it's not in the contract. All right, sorry, we're supposed to keep that up too. Now I can call you daddy in another frame of reference. Now I can call you daddy in front of other people.
看，这太令人兴奋了。你是我们的播客教父之一。我想在合同里，你要求我们这样称呼你。所以我们很高兴能参与其中。我表现得好像合同里没写一样。好吧，抱歉，我们也得保持这个设定。现在我可以在另一个框架下叫你爸爸了。现在我可以在别人面前叫你爸爸了。
If I had a dollar, okay, yeah, tell us. So basically John and I have been best friends and comedy partners for a long, long time and we hosted a travel show called 101 Places to Party Before You Die, which is on Max. And we like to indulge and we kind of live by this lifestyle of like when in Rome and oftentimes that Rome is Las Vegas.
如果我有一美元，好吧，是的，告诉我们。基本上，John 和我作为最好的朋友和喜剧搭档已经很长很长一段时间了，我们主持过一个名为《101 Places to Party Before You Die》（死前必去的 101 个派对地点）的旅游节目，在 Max 上播出。我们喜欢放纵，我们有点遵循这种生活方式，比如入乡随俗，而那个“乡”往往就是拉斯维加斯。
So it's like, we tend to get down and we find ourselves kind of growing up a little bit and thinking, well, we're in our early 40s now and like you do have to counteract. Speak for yourself, John, early 40s. Are you mid 40s? Are you calling yourself mid 40s now and like you do have to counteract speaking for yourself John early 40s Are you mid 40s? That's that's how the term mid started Emphasis on the mid over here tech availed to play Sam Fried
所以我们倾向于尽情狂欢，但我们发现自己有点长大了，心想，好吧，我们现在 40 出头了，你确实得抵消一下。John，别替我说话，40 出头。你是在说自己 40 多岁吗？你现在管自己叫 40 多岁吗？那就是“中”这个词的由来。强调一下这里的“中”，技术上可以玩 Sam Fried。
I'm on ice. I'm on ice. I'm on ice for Sam Freed. Put a pin in me. I'm trying to play Jack Black's before pictures. So I'm on ice. Ah! But so we took an interest, we both have an interest in staying alive as long as we can. It's so good. You know, it's such a thing that all of a sudden
我在冰上。我在冰上。我在冰上，为了 Sam Freed。先暂停一下。我正试着扮演 Jack Black 的“之前”照片。所以我被搁置了。啊！但我们产生了兴趣，我们俩都有兴趣尽可能长久地保持活力。太棒了。你知道，这突然变成了一件
you try to, you find yourself talking about, right? Everybody. Right, in your 20s and 30s, you just party, you eat whatever you want, you drink whatever you want, you go anywhere, you know, right, in your thirties, in your twenties and thirties, it's just part of you eat whatever you want, you drink whatever you want, you do go anywhere, you do anybody you want. Like anything, anything that brings like pleasure or whatever.
你试着去谈论的事情，对吧？每个人。对，在 20 多岁和 30 多岁时，你只是去派对，想吃什么就吃什么，想喝什么就喝什么，去任何地方，你知道，对，在 30 多岁，在 20 多岁和 30 多岁时，这只是你的一部分，你想吃什么就吃什么，想喝什么就喝什么，去任何地方，你想和谁在一起就和谁在一起。就像任何能带来快乐的东西，或者其他什么。
And then all of a sudden you find yourself. With lower back pain. Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly. You're like, you talk to your, hey man, what's going on with it? Do you have this problem too? Like, does it hurt when you pee? Or like whatever it is, right?
然后突然间你发现自己。下背部疼痛。是的，是的，是的，没错。你就像，你和你的朋友说，嘿伙计，这怎么回事？你也有这个问题吗？比如，撒尿的时候疼吗？或者类似的事情，对吧？
And you start talking about it. I noticed that too, it's like. It. Part of the impetus to the show was we wanted to talk to health and wellness professionals to learn more and bring that information to other people but also once you're a certain age all your conversations with even comics if you're not shit talking another comic the thing you're talking about is like yeah have you started taking fish oil yet are you doing vitamin C tablets? Or whatever? It's like, what are you streaming and what's wrong with you physically?
然后你开始谈论它。我也注意到了，就像。它是。节目动力的一部分是我们想和健康与保健专家交谈，了解更多信息并将其带给其他人，但一旦你到了某个年龄，你所有的谈话，即使是和喜剧演员，如果你不是在说另一个喜剧演员的坏话，你谈论的事情就是，是的，你开始吃鱼油了吗？你在吃维生素 C 片吗？或者其他什么？就像，你在看什么流媒体，你身体有什么毛病？
Yes, exactly. That's a great one. What are you watching and what's wrong with you? How are your streams, your piss and your movies? Yeah. Right, exactly. Weak, all of them weak. Dribbly.
是的，没错。那是个好问题。你在看什么，你有什么毛病？你的尿流、你的排泄和你的电影怎么样？是的。对，没错。虚弱，全都虚弱。滴滴答答的。
Dribbly. So can you tell us like one of the things that was the most, I know you probably get asked this a lot, but one of the most eye-opening things are the things that you implement now more than ever. Well, I mean, it runs the gamut from like, we had an immunologist on from the NIH who told us one of the simple things you can do is add,
滴滴答答的。所以你能告诉我们，我知道你可能经常被问到这个问题，但最让你大开眼界的事情之一，或者你现在比以往任何时候都更付诸实践的事情是什么？嗯，我的意思是，范围很广，比如我们请了一位来自 NIH 的免疫学家，她告诉我们你可以做的简单事情之一是添加，
I'm gonna say it wrong, but cruciferous. You got it. Cruciferous vegetables into your diet. And now we use that word just to kind of feed big dog you a little bit, Sean, but that means broccoli and cauliflower. We're so happy to have learned it that we bring it up in every conversation. So basically she was like, those are the vegetables
我会说错，但十字花科。你说对了。十字花科蔬菜加入你的饮食中。现在我们用这个词只是为了让你稍微有点优越感，Sean，但这指的是西兰花和花椰菜。我们很高兴学到了这个词，以至于我们在每次谈话中都会提到它。所以基本上她是说，那些是蔬菜
that are really worth your- What do you mean, like if you just eat those, you're good? They're nutrient dense. They're nutrient dense and they're worth it to add to your diet. If you're not eating them, get them in. So a general physician would say, okay, if you're ordering Chinese food,
真正值得你——你是什么意思，就像如果你只吃那些，你就没事了？它们营养丰富。它们营养丰富，值得加入你的饮食。如果你不吃它们，就把它们加进去。所以全科医生会说，好吧，如果你在点中餐，
chicken and broccoli is not a bad order because you're getting broccoli. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. You know. Okay, very good. It's simple things on that level. But then we also had a friend on, Elna, who told us that salvia can transport you to the quantum realm and you can experience
鸡肉西兰花是个不错的选择，因为你吃到了西兰花。是的，是的，是的，是的，是的。你知道。好的，非常好。那是那个层面的简单事情。但我们也请了一位朋友，Elna，她告诉我们鼠尾草可以把你传送到量子领域，你可以体验
true formlessness. Now I don't know if I'm gonna bring that into my routine, my health routine, adding some rips of salvia, but this is the kind of information you can get at Staying Alive. I love that, it's everything I'm for, because I need this. The other day, literally just a week ago,
真正的无形状态。现在我不知道我是否会把那个加入我的日常生活中，我的健康常规，加点鼠尾草，但这就是你可以在《Staying Alive》中获得的信息。我喜欢这个，这是我所支持的一切，因为我需要这个。前几天，就在一周前，
Will Arnett said to me, I said, he goes, what'd you do yesterday? And I was like I have this lunch with an agent of mine and then and he goes lunch and I go yeah I like to keep my dinners free and he goes from what vegetables I never eat No, it's crazy that I'm in my but I super late 20s and I'm being told eat more vegetables and I'm taking that as like Holy shit, I haven't really considered that Yeah, I mean I had it in juice like that's just like the way that I'm getting it
Will Arnett 对我说，我说，他问，你昨天做了什么？我说我有个经纪人的午餐，然后他说午餐，我说对，我喜欢把晚餐空出来，他说从什么蔬菜我从来不吃。不，我 20 多岁末期却被告知多吃蔬菜，这很疯狂，我把它当作，天哪，我真的没考虑过那个。是的，我的意思是我是以果汁的形式摄入的，那只是我摄入它的方式
in a juice form Stuff a cauliflower into my blunt There's already one there remote control out of there first. My vibrating, my vibrating cauliflower. His television remote. That only Adam has the remote to. All right, we're gonna listen to the trailer really quick, here we go. Listen up podcast fans, Joe Rogan, Theo Vaughn, Tim Dillon won't be on our show at all.
以果汁的形式。把花椰菜塞进我的大麻烟卷里。那里已经有一个了，先把遥控器拿出来。我振动的，我振动花椰菜。他的电视遥控器。只有 Adam 有那个遥控器。好了，我们要快速听一下预告片，开始吧。听好了播客粉丝们，Joe Rogan, Theo Vaughn, Tim Dillon 完全不会出现在我们的节目中。
They've said no. They've said no. Because of our beliefs. That's Adam Pally. That's John Gabris. They said no. They said no. Because of our beliefs. Ha ha ha ha. Ha ha ha ha. That's Adam Pally. That's John Gabras. And we are the co-hosts of Smartless Media's new podcast called Staying Alive.
他们拒绝了。他们拒绝了。因为我们的信仰。那是 Adam Pally。那是 John Gabrus。他们拒绝了。他们拒绝了。因为我们的信仰。哈哈哈哈。哈哈哈哈。那是 Adam Pally。那是 John Gabrus。我们是 Smartless Media 新播客《Staying Alive》的联合主持人。
That's right, Staying Alive, our new health and wellness podcast that is neither for the healthy or well. Well, it's maybe for health by health. Ha ha ha ha. We'll have guests like our friend actor Jerry O'Connell. Pally, you are looking good. Well, it's maybe for health by health We'll have guests like our friend actor Jerry O'Connell. Pally you are looking good. Thank you I've seen you not looking good. Yeah, and you're looking good. Thank you. You're not the first guest to say I've seen you look worse Comedian Paul Scheer. I love the cold plunge. I found a lot of success. Do you have one in your house? I do I also flooded my house with it, but that's why it's outside. It's outside.
没错，《Staying Alive》，我们新的健康与保健播客，既不适合健康的人，也不适合身体好的人。嗯，也许是为了健康，通过健康。哈哈哈哈。我们将有嘉宾，比如我们的朋友演员 Jerry O'Connell。Pally，你看起来不错。嗯，也许是为了健康，通过健康。我们将有嘉宾，比如我们的朋友演员 Jerry O'Connell。Pally 你看起来不错。谢谢。我见过你看起来不好的样子。是的，你看起来不错。谢谢。你不是第一个说“我见过你看起来更糟”的嘉宾。喜剧演员 Paul Scheer。我喜欢冷水浴。我发现很成功。你家里有一个吗？我有。我也把它淹了，但这就是为什么它在外面。它在外面。
Ketamine therapist Dr. Steven Radowitz. It's called spiritual herd immunity. Now when you're in this place, I start to see through those things. I believe in spiritual herd immunity because I'm a spiritual anti-vaxxer. Yeah. So I think that that's kind of the only way.
氯胺酮治疗师 Steven Radowitz 博士。这叫精神群体免疫。现在当你处于这个位置时，我开始看穿那些事情。我相信精神群体免疫，因为我是一个精神上的反疫苗者。是的。所以我认为那是唯一的方法。
Eggo Wodum talking to us about how she hates breakfast. Here's my thing is I don't have an appetite in the morning because I'm eating up until the minute I close my eyes. And I'm serious. Cardiologist Dr. Amar Sheer. Stress actually it affects the blood pressure so as much as you can kind of reduce your stress. And it's chill to do coke right?
Eggo Wodum 和我们谈论她是如何讨厌早餐的。我的情况是，我早上没有胃口，因为我一直吃到闭眼的那一刻。我是认真的。心脏病专家 Amar Sheer 博士。压力实际上会影响血压，所以尽可能减少压力。而且吸食可卡因很酷，对吧？
Definitely don't do coke. Okay, alright, not chill to do coke. right? Definitely don't do coke. Okay, alright, not chill to do coke. Jillian Bell. I think it's natural also for our age too, like... Jillian's 25, and you and I... I'm a hard 25. You're a hard 25, yeah, you've lived a life. And I'm a road hard 34.
绝对不要吸食可卡因。好的，好吧，吸食可卡因不酷。对吧？绝对不要吸食可卡因。好的，好吧，吸食可卡因不酷。Jillian Bell。我认为这对于我们的年龄来说也很自然，就像……Jillian 25 岁，你和我……我是硬核 25 岁。你是硬核 25 岁，是的，你经历过生活。而我是饱经风霜的 34 岁。
And I'm not that hard, and 43. And so many more, so many more. You know, Adam and I, we may not be wellness experts, but I can tell you this. We are curious freaks who love to talk about this shit. And we've done enough harm to our bodies to know that now's the time to maybe make a change. Yeah, we can't say we can make a U-turn in our lives,
而我没那么硬，43 岁。还有更多，还有更多。你知道，Adam 和我，我们可能不是健康专家，但我可以告诉你这一点。我们是好奇的怪胎，喜欢谈论这些狗屁。我们对自己的身体造成的伤害已经足够多，知道现在是时候做出改变了。是的，我们不能说我们能让生活来个大转弯，
but at least we could pump the brakes a little. And maybe make a left. Hey, two wrongs don't make a left. Yeah. Hey, two wrongs don't make a left. Right. Correct. Staying Alive premieres April 24th anywhere you get your podcasts. Get them a week early and ad free
但至少我们可以稍微踩踩刹车。也许向左转。嘿，两个错误不能变成一个左转。是的。嘿，两个错误不能变成一个左转。对。正确。《Staying Alive》将于 4 月 24 日在你获取播客的任何地方首播。提前一周收听并无广告版，
with SiriusXM Podcast Plus on Apple Podcasts. Visit SiriusXM Podcast Plus to start your free trial today. Check out the video version of the show on YouTube on the Smartless Media channel. Yeah, and why don't you do us a favor in the meantime? You guys you're awesome, I can't wait for everybody to hear this Adam Pally John gabris Staying alive again premieres Thursday April 24th. Here's a fucking hilarious. Great idea for a show. I will totally be listening. Thank you for doing it.
通过 Apple Podcasts 上的 SiriusXM Podcast Plus。访问 SiriusXM Podcast Plus 立即开始免费试用。在 YouTube 的 Smartless Media 频道上查看节目的视频版本。是的，在此期间你能帮我们个忙吗？你们太棒了，我迫不及待想让大家听到这个。Adam Pally，John Gabrus，《Staying Alive》再次于 4 月 24 日星期四首播。这是一个该死的好笑的节目点子。我一定会听的。谢谢你们做这个。
Thank you, Shawnee. Thank you for not only having us here, but green lighting us in general. Thank you for the green light. Guys, it was exhausting green lighting you. I know, you really, you carried us over that finish line. We need someone to push the ball uphill like you, Shawnee. And you are gonna delete all the photos you said, right?
谢谢你，Shawnee。谢谢你不仅让我们在这里，还为我们开了绿灯。谢谢你的绿灯。伙计们，给你们开绿灯太累人了。我知道，你真的把我们带过了终点线。我们需要像你这样的人把球推上山，Shawnee。而且你会删除你说的所有照片，对吧？
That's it, done, done and done. Okay, thank you. We're like Sean Spacey over there. That's fucking hilarious. Smart. Blast. Media. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
就是这样，完成了，完成了，完成了。好的，谢谢。我们就像那边的 Sean Spacey。那真是太搞笑了。Smart. Blast. Media。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。